[Music]
Tamm mom has another world exclusive for
us we're debuting her new single glossy
first I'm going to take you behind the
scenes of the recording session we had
two reporters documenting her every step
Wow surely and lament which is momentum
mom calls him lament Tim I'm teamed up
again with her partner Adam Barda lost
he was going to address her recent coma
remember I told you she was in a coma
yes
Tamm mom's process is probably different
from every other artist on the planet
she doesn't like to be tied down by
lyrics anything written down she just
sings from the heart I am lost why down
bhakti going into a coma is no beat down
below I am dying I can't do it Oh feelin
real bossy she's bossy oh yeah she's
bossy I'm glossy glossy glossy but oh
yeah he's bossy yeah Wow
Adam seems to jump in when she gets
frustrated he never stops oh he doesn't
jump it in yeah I can't I can't do it
Adam Barda picks up the slack went and
mom is struggling to find the right
lyric sometimes Adam gets carried away
in tammim has trouble getting back into
this taking over
she was resuscitated yeah she's alive
she's alive she's alive
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
with the word resuscitation after the
recording session tan mom went to a
beauty clinic because as you know
recording is rough and you have to be
youthful to stay relevant right so tan
mom wanted her face worked on before the
song release Vampire Facelift vampire
facials
yeah this can't be good it's supposedly
Robin makes your skin more youthful how
could you say that all right so here's
exclusive tape now of tan mom consulting
with Corinna the woman who owns the
place and does the procedure Corinna the
Vampire Facelift involves injections of
the platelet-rich plasma
while the vampire facial involves micro
needling and drilling of the platelets
into the skin what we are going to do
today we are going to take some blood
from your vein and we are going to
process it extract the platelets all the
goodness from your blood and we are
going to give it about my face my blood
oh my gosh
oh my gosh Katrina I'm so tan mom kept
trying to say Karina's name but she
couldn't get a vs. there you go
Oh Colby or Yanukovych Colby cheese kle
of the tree yes you okay I got it
it's a V cake thank you call the beach
[Laughter]
next Karina started the Vampire Facelift
while the machine was poking thousands
of holes in her face tan mom thought the
machine was saying lament it's a great
job we're met because they have a lot of
art now it certainly hurt yeah now it's
ever hurt Wow
actually gave you the full treatment
Ajit look any different afterward Wow
look at a mob puppet she looks
completely different
[Music]
[Music]
tamam are you excited we're about to
debut your new song I couldn't breathe
no I'm so excited right this is the song
la see the world premiere of Tam mom's
new song oh my god
like John and what just once
kiss
you got you
feeling real about the everyone
we'll make it real
[Music]
my glossy comecomecome
on the floor can't you understand our to
take anymore
victory with a needle
six equations to take me with your
needles and your pins all I do
horny - you're no wonder or draw bustles
I hate them hopper me but now I've lost
yeah okay I forgot about the corona my
favorite
[Music]
[Music]
my god let's go all the way yeah that's
just a moment just once juice
my mom would make a great Joker in the
Batman sir oh it opens up and she's
getting a Vampire Facelift sucking the
blood out of people and then then she
goes to battle with Batman ha ha soon it
will be yours
well Gotham oh well ok I said I was
taking over town
I would love to be an actress but I
always how do they remember over the
line I'm you don't know who you are
that's right
part-2 needle or something that stuck in
my butt I am so sick and tired of
getting [ __ ]
[Music]
it's it's a killer song tan mom you've
done it again thank you